[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
aquí en directo América por ello me
acompaña en el estudio mi compañero
Jorge Hurtado Jorge bienvenido una
semana bastante difícil en el mundo para
los criptoactivos Así es sobre todo tras
el colapso de uno de sus principales
exchange la empresa ftx la empresa fue
fundada en 2019 y creció rápidamente
hasta entrar en el top 5 de los
principales sitios de intercambio de
criptomonedas del mundo su fundador Sam
backman Fred construyó una fortuna que
pasó de 16 mil millones de dólares a 0
en solamente unos días FX reportó un
déficit de unos 8.000 millones de
dólares e incluso buscó la protección de
la bancarrota con las autoridades de
Estados Unidos a los problemas de
liquidez que sufría se sumó una
investigación abierta por el regulador
estadounidense sobre cómo usaba el
dinero de los clientes lo que provocó
una retirada masiva de fondos para
entender este golpe al mercado de
criptomonedas que provocó ftx
conversamos con Mauricio Tovar
cofundador de la plataforma trópicos.com
quienes estén Argentina precisamente
participando de la bitcoin el mayor
evento sobre criptomonedas de América
Latina le preguntamos Cuál es el
sentimiento de los inversores tras esta
noticia Bueno hay mucha preocupación por
un lado pues es ftx es era el tercer
exchange o intercambio servicio de
intercambio de criptomonedas a nivel
global más grande se tenía una imagen
muy positiva de sus finanzas en el
ecosistema en general entonces esto Toma
por sorpresa a todos creo que hay un
sentimiento de preocupación por las
personas que están perdiendo su dinero y
hay un sentimiento de preocupación
también porque ftx puede desencadenar
una serie de cierres de otros proyectos
donde ftx tenía dinero invertido y que
había comprometido algunos recursos y no
va a poder cumplirlos o donde muchos
proyectos están poniendo su dinero en
ftx Y no van a poder sacarlos lo que les
va a ayudar a tomar decisiones duras
Jorge el colapso de esta empresa hizo
caer el bitcoin y otras criptomonedas el
bitcoin se desplomó hasta un 8% antes de
recuperar algo de terreno el éter y
otros tokens que son un poco más
pequeños también se desplomaron solana
otro famoso cayó un 10% porque estaba
respaldada por el fondo de cobertura
Alameda resorts vinculada con Netflix
esta y otras docenas de empresas
afiliadas presentaron una solicitud de
quiebra en Delaware la quiebra afectará
Aproximadamente a unas 130 compañías
ahora el mayor temor es el efecto
contagio que pueda provocar esta quiebra
de ftx sobre esto opinó nuestro invitado
sí Ya empezaron algunos de los contagios
incluso una empresa de préstamos
centralizado muy grande que se llama
blog Five ya anunció que que detiene los
retiros de los de las criptomonedas de
su plataforma porque básicamente ellos
han estado en problemas financieros hace
un tiempo y quien los había rescatado
era precisamente ftx
ftx al entrar en quiebra ftx
evidentemente no puede cumplir con esos
compromisos que tenía con
bloodfight y blog Fight no va a poder
responder por lo menos por ese lado y
así como ese caso hay muchísimos otros
proyectos que tenían ligas o operaciones
ftx o que estaban esperando compromisos
de inversiones otro de ellos es voy ayer
una empresa de de Singapur Entonces si
vamos a ver un efecto contagio todavía
no sabemos la magnitud la información
está saliendo por partes pero se espera
que pase Y esta semana la Casa Blanca
dijo que continuaban monitoreando la
situación incluso dijeron O abrieron la
posibilidad nuevamente a regular Este
mercado que es algo que se ha discutido
en muchos países Durante los últimos
años Lo cierto es que el mercado está
pasando por algo que los expertos llaman
el cripto invierno una forma bajista
digamos de enfrentar esta recesión
económica que también se está manejando
en el mundo y la pregunta que siempre
surge en estos momentos es es el final o
no de las criptomonedas se lo
preguntamos a nuestro invitado y esto
Dijo Cristo invierno ya lleva varios
meses creo que ya va para el para el año
de de empezar con estos precios bajos
pero algo que es muy importante es
diferenciar los fundamentales de la
tecnología con servicios centralizados
que ofrecen servicios alrededor de las
criptomonedas y es las la tecnología
está en su mejor momento bitcoin e
incluso Está mejor ahora que hace un año
donde tuvo máximos ethereum está incluso
mejor ahora que es un año que tuvo
máximos Pero estos proyectos que
utilizan o que intermedian entre el
mundo tradicional y el mundo de las
criptomonedas son los que con su falta
de transparencia con sus malos manejos
han generado la desconfianza pero la
tecnología no ha cambiado en
absolutamente nada los fundamentales de
el valor que ofrecen de darle poder
controlar del dinero y de sus
propiedades a la gente o poder
transferir a costos muy bajos y de
manera casi instantánea entre muchos
otros siguen vigentes y no han cambiado
Simplemente hay malos actores de la
industria lastimosamente muy grandes y
como lo dices no es el único ftx pero
eso no significa que la industria no
genere el valor que se espera que genere
simplemente así son los ciclos de
Mercado y normalmente en los ciclos
bajistas llegan todas las malas noticias
y se filtran los malos actores y es
parte también del proceso Jorge Pues a
usted muchas gracias por esta ampliación
económica hasta la próxima bueno y ahora
continuamos aquí en directo América
vamos con directo
[Música]